james slater the NFL network covers the
Cowboys been all over this story and she
joins us now Jane good morning thanks
for joining us what can you tell us
about this good morning well I wasn't
shocked by the retirement or this latest
news about him going to CBS you know it
was I think the first week thursday i
got a phone call right after the mort
tweet went out that the cowboys were
looking to involve themselves in a trade
with the broncos and with the Texans and
the phone call that i refused was jane
he is not going to go anywhere trust me
he's retiring and as I was sort of
educated about this conversation that he
had with someone very close to him a
mentor for years the conversation was
such that Tony just has not been able to
move past dallas in the situation that
was last year it's my understanding that
he still feels as though the team was
taken from him that this was the best
team that the Cowboys had assembled
since coming to dallas as an undrafted
free agent and taking over the starter
from Drew Bledsoe and that he was
frustrated with the fact that here he
was coming back from the back injury and
we saw the practice throwing missiles
after returning and not being able to
compete for that job and as he started
to really think about his life after
Dallas he was having a really hard time
reconciling that that life involves
another team namely Denver and or
Houston it was my sense that it was a
struggle because it was a new playbook
it was a new fan base a new locker room
and then also consider that he's enjoyed
a very cozy and unique relationship with
management that he wouldn't necessarily
get somewhere else and he knows that
that window was closing and you're just
there's a lot of expectations at 37 to
go ahead and sort of recreate the
security that he had in Dallas and then
also hope for success I mean it's hard
enough to get a team to a Super Bowl and
you know they might look good on paper
now but she used to say that team looks
the same during the regular season so as
he weighed all those options
he kept throwing out things like you
know Jim Nantz and I have been talking
we have a great relationship you know
what if I considered this move to
broadcasting so it's my sense that those
conversations that already sort of
happened in the works and maybe Jim
Nantz was you know doing some stuff for
him behind the scenes to take what was
once just a casual discussion between
these two to the brass and saying now
there's a genuine interest and then that
a situation created itself and as people
kept asking me you know okay which Goods
you cmn CBS made the most sense because
he was essentially being set up to
succeed instead of fail by having this
mentor on his side having someone that
would ensure his success just seemed
like the best possible move so not
shocked after the conversation that I
had a couple of weeks ago and I think
this is the best situation not only for
him at 37 having a child on the way and
not having a strong interest to reinvest
in the team but also for Jerry Jones no
one can a second guess this decision now
that the charea decided to move on with
this young dak Prescott who won 13 games
last season and decided to pass on a guy
like Tony Romo who some still feel like
he may have been able to get it done
with this team in in the way that it's
set up right now okay but Jane the
timing of it is what I find baffling
that we kept waiting at tony was
frustrated that they weren't going to
release him it was going to be after the
draft closer to training camp then they
were waiting for trade offers not there
then there was the report that now he's
free to talk to any GM if he wants to
yesterday then all of a sudden Tony
Romo's decides that he's retiring from
football like it doesn't make sense the
timeline of this thing's don't make a
lot of sense all the time down in Dallas
but its life it's my understanding that
the cowboys and Tony Romo specifically
the Jones family Jerry Jones and Stephen
Jones were very much in contact with
Tony throughout this process that
perhaps and we've seen it done before in
Dallas I don't know this for certain but
talking to a number of people I want to
be on the same page on this when we're
talking behind the scenes that perhaps
hearing the Cowboys essentially fell on
the sword for Tony because he was sort
of going
back and forth and the market wasn't
what he thought it would be Jerry fell
on the sword said we don't have a
timetable for this decision the decision
could come at a training camp its buying
him some time to explore these options
with these other teams while also
creating a sense of urgency for these
networks that are maybe mulling whether
or not they want to bring Tony on board
if there's still a perceived interest
that he could play football maybe there
is a sense of urgency now so bring a
deal to the table so it is my
understanding that everyone was still
very much in cahoots if there was
anything that may be both sides did it
was Miss valued what that market would
have been and miss played this situation
a little bit by giving him some extra
time to sit on this roster and not have
these willing suitors court him rolling
out the red carpet like Denver did for
Peyton Manning it might have played into
this decision will you know if I'm got
teams are not willing to make a trade if
I've got teams that are looking at a
contract that's contingent on my health
I'm not going to get a huge signing
bonus I'm not going to make a lot of
money with this team in other words
they're not investing as heavily as i
thought they might do i want to invest
as heavily as n and so i think there
were a couple of things that came into
play here ah but to suggest that jerry
jones and the cowboys violated that do
right role i'm not getting the sense of
that took place talking to james slater
NFL Network reporter and her twitter
handle is at slater NFL i guess this is
ideal for everybody then that Jerry
Jones gets to have Tony retire a cowboy
he doesn't play for Houston and he goes
into the broadcasting field and replaces
Phil Simms I'm curious you've been
around Tony Romo for a while how will he
do as a broadcaster you know he is
naturally charismatic I mean you've seen
just some of his bits even with the
Jimmy Kimmel and you've seen him on
television I I think the only thing that
he will probably struggle with is giving
his opinion and I think that that's
something that a lot of musical jacket
struggle with as they make that
transition from football to TV some
people do it successfully others end up
going back to football Marco
so used to do radio with me in Dallas
and he used to tell me that was one of
the hardest things that he ever did and
now he's back doing the offensive line
coaching for the Cowboys I think that's
going to be probably the hardest thing
for joining Robin what people don't
realize about Antonius he does have a
bit of a fragile ego he is concerned
what people think about him and so I
think if that is going to be his biggest
challenge in terms of natural charisma
his ability to talk on television you
saw that firsthand with that concession
speech very well written his wife has a
background in broadcasting she was a
sports reporter in Dallas I think she
can help navigate him he's got a lot of
friends in the business I don't think
it's going to be an issue of him
committing to the craft and trying to
get better at it I think if anything
what are you going to struggle with is
perhaps inserting his opinion in those
situations and I think all of these guys
learned when they move over to the media
side mclovin give Jane the poll question
let her respond before we say goodbye
will Tony Romo play NFL football again I
wouldn't roll it out I say that because
in his conversations as I was being
educated about the situation leading up
to today he legitimately said what if
the Cowboys were to call me during the
season you know I could come back and
play for them like I could still keep
that door open and my person told him
essentially he was delusional but in his
mind he could still see himself in a
savior role so I wouldn't rule it out i
think that there's still that
competitive drive I think he's a little
frustrated and dealing with the emotions
of the market not being there the way he
had hoped as a 37 year old football
player that was either looking to get
released or traded I think that that
fiber will still burn inside I don't
know if he's going to get bored with
this new lifestyle if some people do
play golf and broadcasting i would say
hang it up and enjoy this new child on
your way and enjoy the second chapter of
your life but i wouldn't rule it out
completely Thank You Jane we appreciate
it I appreciate having me on Lauren
that's changed Slater NFL network
covering the Cowboys this from Mike
Freeman who covers the NFL all
everyone I'm contacting in front offices
believes Romo will be back to play I
like how Jane laid all of this out hey
this is what's going to happen and this
is what Tony wants and needs going to do
this and it do you think you'll play
again yeah the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience